well I'm a big lover of the young and I
in my musical career I sponsor eight
mute young musicians year to go to the
Royal Academy and because we have a
sports management company my management
company now we thought it would be good
idea to set up a similar foundation to
help young sportsmen to get a grant
every year to help them from the ages of
like 12 to 18 and so we've hopefully
will raise a half a million tonight and
that'll all go to the fund and so for
the next eight years it means that 20
kids can get a two thousand pound grant
that normally couldn't get any money and
it's just a way of supplementing their
incomes and giving them some hope for
the future and you know I'm a big lover
of youth I love young musicians and
young athletes and I just wanted to do
something to help aspiring athletes that
may be running into a cul-de-sac you
know and couldn't get any funding and
that's all important that these those
early stages how are you going to choose
those that they get the grants that get
the funds I think that would be a
decision made by a company and the
people who associate you on the
Foundation Board will you know it'll
only be Olympic sports it won't be
anything you know it'll be the whole
gamut of Olympic sports not golf and not
football
but the all the other sports cycling a
question ISM you know swimming judo
boxing wrestling although if judo still
in there I think was taken out the last
Olympics or wrestling the Australia
anyway we represent a lot of young
athletes I'm in Laura trot and Jason
Kennedy who both Olympic medal winners
grant Thomas who got chosen for the Tour
de France this week for the fifth time
Richard Kielty the world indoor hunter
60 meter champion Bob young was a young
Luxembourg cyclist adam yates an amazing
cyclist and then swift another amazing
cyclist so you know we've got a lot of a
talent on our hands already and we're
looking to explore other sports other
than cycling and other than athletics
but I like to consider on the Olympic
sport and the sports that don't get the
funding and the athletes that don't get
the help that you know every footballer
has an agent so you know it's not really
worth your not doing that it's the other
sports that need help and in
encouragement and to earn money outside
of what they do tell me about that you
know flowing from the Olympics
concentrating on Olympic sports here
2012 I mean we all remember just what a
great summer of sport that was so
inspiring for everybody it was great for
the country great I mean that one
evening when there were three track
goals for example and I got so into the
cycling at the velodrome and on the road
and I think Bradley Wiggins you know did
so much by winning the Tour de France
and God I saw so much interest in in the
cycling and it was an amazing amazing
feeling in this country and and it was
an example of what we can do if we're
encouraged and and can reach our goals
and and you know we can match the best
but we have to encourage people at a
young age hmm and give them some hope
and I'm just trying to do this because
you know what music and sport are great
common denominator
most sportsmen want to be musicians and
most musicians want to be sportsmen I
come from a footballing family my cousin
played football for Nottingham Forest
Roy Dwight scored the first goal in the
1957 Cup final against Luton and so I've
always been involved in sport and I've
always loved sport so to be able to help
these young kids you know football and
support bring people together yeah they
do you know and it's it's a great thing
and I just I've always loves sports here
I'm at 67 years of age starting this
foundation to help people you know my
son you know he won't need a grant
because I'll be able to afford to play
but it's the future of my son's
generation and the generation after him
and you know the ones that are coming
through to 10 or 11 years old can you
see I mean can you see him getting
interested in sport is he kicking a ball
around oh yeah
loves a place tennis he's playing tennis
he loved he loved to giggle ball around
there both do and you know it's it's I
just hope they become sportsmen because
it's just a great way of meeting not
going to music um right now this playing
sport is such a great social thing if
you play sport you know and and it's
great to have a game of soccer or game
of tennis or give a rugby or whatever it
breeds a social thing where you all and
you're you're there with your mates or
you make new friends and you travel and
you play other people and you make new
friends but so it's a wonderful
wonderful social thing to do as well as
a sporting Athol anything to do
tell me about then I mean what is
passion when you're demonstrating it
here and the way you're joining up there
the two activities sport and music do
you
approach a concert like tonight insight
in a slightly different way does it does
it mean more to you well you know you've
got to do
I just every concert is different I
approach it as if it's my last concert
and I always try and go out and give it
the best I'm very lucky to have a whole
catalog of songs that I can choose from
and I still love it and singing those
songs because they're very good songs so
when I get bored with what I do each
concert is a test and you know that last
week at this time we were playing in Li
to 18,000 people at the Rugby League
club and now we're playing to 5,000
people in a very sedate sitting in Stoke
Park and on Thursday night I was playing
at my house in my in a gallery of a
hundred people raising money for AIDS
and so three different shows and in a
week and you've all got to pull them off
and if I can't do that off now by the
tide been doing it for 47 years I've
been really
I'm not that much but it's the Bears I
do
this one's for you no no Ashley this
question as well as another festival
taking place some this very evening hand
over this weekend with a few more
thousand people involved a couple of
hours west of where we are talking about
Glastonbury are we ever going to see Sir
Elton there I don't know I've never
really been asked so I played Bestival
last year Glastonbury is you know the
creme de la creme of festival is you
know if you look at all the main acts
that are on the stage on that grade or
the headline acts and then you go to the
other stages and you see every important
young musician that's coming up every
important young musician that's great
and I think that's an accrued credit to
Glastonbury I mean just look at the
smaller stages and you see everybody you
want to see in music practically so you
know it's any any time people come
together to celebrate music in a joyous
atmosphere it can't be bad
come on let's tell me a little bit about
you mentioned that we all know about the
huge amount of work you've done in
particular for age charities and the
huge amount of money you've raised you
you wrote an article in the independent
today along with Norman Fowler former
secretary State for Health of course you
talked there very passionately and very
interestingly about yes the vast strides
we've made in this country when it comes
to to gay rights to understanding to
civil partnerships to equal marriage and
things like that but you made the point
there's still a lot of work to be done
in the UK and in actual fact things have
got worse for a lot of gay and
transgender people in many many other
countries around the world oh yeah
globally no we seem to have gone
backwards over the last 18 months in
certain areas and it's cause I've
mentioned this on state on Thursday
night and I said you know as long as I'm
alive until I'm you know I will fight
for people's rights anybody whose human
rights are wronged or taken away from
them I will try and fight them I will
try and go to Russia I am going to
Russia in December on November and I
will try and meet Putin and I will try
and talk to him I don't know what good
it'll do but unless you build a bridge
it's no good putting up a border so I'm
not talking to these people the only
thing that gets sold is by talking to
people and if I have the talent or any
talent of trying to help in that
situation then I'm trying to try and do
it I mean
I may not achieve anything but I have to
try and I have there's so many people
out there who is living a life of hell
and I'm living a life of you know luxury
and I have my human rights intact and I
won't forget as a aids organization we
support the marginalized as well you
know the very very poor people that are
getting left behind the drug users the
people in prison you know if we leave
people behind in society then society is
going to crumble we have to do on this
journey of AIDS and human rights we have
to try and take everyone with us and I
deeply believe that and many people
might disagree me but I'm certainly you
know if anyone doesn't have their basic
civil rights I get crazy
one or the other point you make in the
article when it comes to what more needs
to be done in the United Kingdom is that
the Church of England's attitude is must
be diplomatic about it's not really very
helpful at the moment I know but they're
a sign of hope but I think the new
Archbishop of Canterbury is doing a good
job so far the new pope has done
wonderful I mean he's excited me so much
by his humanity and taking everything
down to the humility of faith no matter
what it is what face you have what
religion you have who you believe in
what you believe in he stripped it down
to the bare bones and said it's all
basically about love and taking
everybody in inclusiveness and that has
to be encouraged by the Church of
England as well I am we have a long way
to go but we have made great strides
let's not you know 30 years ago I
couldn't have imagined this would have
happened now in my country so I'm very
grateful for that but you ever think the
church I mean the church do you think it
should allow its clergy same-sex clergy
to get married of course and and and and
I don't see why Catholic priests have to
be celibate it's crazy you know these
are old and stupid things and the church
hierarchy might be you know up in arms
about it the traditionalist but times
have changed we live in a different time
change if Jesus Christ was alive today I
cannot see him as the Christian person
that he was and the great person that he
was saying this could not happen he was
all about love and compassion and
forgiveness and trying to bring people
together and that
is what the church should be about and
lastly when we're going to see you and
David getting married well we can't get
married this year because we had a civil
partnership and I think the government
kind of messed that one up and I've done
they we can get married till next year
however when we do do it it'll be very
quiet I'm gonna be very off-the-cuff not
me we had our big shebang with me at a
civil union so um but we will and that's
it's a great opportunity to take
advantage of the new laws and to
celebrate it we're very lucky in this
country to be able to have that
advantage and have that position to be
in being able to marry your partner it's
a huge way we've come a long long way
and for that the the church deserve
credit
that's your song
thank you